[Music]
Tylar Cameron's relationship with gigi
hadid is a thing of the past but that's
not stopping fans from speculating about
the model's recent pregnancy news I work
on Wednesday the former Bachelorette
contestant hopped on instagram live and
when one fan commented quote congrats on
becoming the father gigi is preg Tyler
was well not here for that y'all are
wrong in the comments
Tyler and Gigi dated for a hot minute at
the end of last summer but by early
october ET confirmed that they'd called
it quits then Gigi reconciled with her
on and off boyfriend Zayn Malik
he's obviously so gorgeous but really
the way that we could have conversations
and kind of just were really interested
in the same things and it was really
easy
on Tuesday ET confirmed that the pair is
expecting their first child together I'm
feeling so overwhelmed with happiness
and excitement a source tells ET quote
the couple recently found out the sex of
the baby and are over the moon adding
that they are excited to be welcoming a
girl to their family the two have been
staying at Gigi's family's Pennsylvania
farm where their quarantine together
amid the corona virus pandemic they
celebrated the model's 25th birthday
over the weekend the blonde beauty
posted a series of pics and videos with
Zayn her mama Yolanda and her younger
sister Bella
and speaking of Gigi's mom the former
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills star
seemingly confirmed her daughter's
pregnancy news when she liked an Elle UK
Instagram post on Thursday featuring a
pic of Gigi and Zayn holding hands the
post included a caption from an
interview Yolanda did with the Dutch
broadcasting station RTL Boulevard
saying she can't wait to be a
grandmother
and we know Yolanda approves of her
granddaughters baby daddy
Thayne is very special to me and you
know he's family the 56 year old gushed
about Zayn 2et back in 2017 he's just a
really good person you know he comes
from very humble beginnings oh he's just
a normal guy and he's he's a good human
being
[Music]